Our Growing Communities: Ō Tātou Hapori
Whanake
Waimakariri is one of the fastest growing
districts in New Zealand and may near 100,000
residents over the next 30 years.
The upcoming review of the District Plan will
ensure the district and its townships have
adequate land zoned for 30 years' growth.
The District Development Strategy will set
out how and where we grow and plan for appropriate
infrastructure to support our expanding population.
Our District - Our Future, Waimakariri 2048
aims to:
So what do you think?
Do you agree with the general growth directions
proposed for our main towns?
Do you support a greater mix of housing choices
and intensification?
Let us know your thoughts and find out more
about the District Development Strategy at
Waimakariri.govt.nz